all right this is a pepper panic saga
level 232 walkthrough tutorial video
uh this is a pretty tough level so what
i'm going to do is
i'm going to play through it and beat it
and explain things like why i'm doing
what i'm doing while i go
this level takes a while so i'm going to
try to play a little bit
on the fast side
but if you played it already you know
that the hard part is getting to the
statues
there's no way to make matches down here
and there's crates in the way in the
beginning so
what we need to do in the beginning is
get rid of the crates
we're going to do that by making shock
wave matches
here we have a choice between two i'm
gonna go ahead and shoot the stage
two crate instead
because it takes two hits to get rid of
that one
all right so now we don't really have
any other
shock waves already set up so
we can see we have a gap here
that we can drop on down so we'll drop
that one down
and shoot another crate
this is really all all you can you know
this is throughout the level this is
what you have to do is set these up it's
it's not always easy but
that's really what you're trying to do
the whole time all right so we can see
we have the gaps
here and we can set this one up directly
so we will
and
this is set up
in l if everything stays in place
but it didn't that's why i added that on
there because
you know he the cat isn't the big he's
not really that big of a deal on this
level he's kind of
just an added annoyance
you kind of try to plan where he's going
to move stuff out of your way but most
of the time
you know he just really isn't a factor
and
what i mean is is that we're not trying
to grow peppers for explosions
at all i mean towards the end we might
if we have the right ones at the bottom
but
other than that like if you have a match
i'll try to find a spot but if you have
a match coming up and you know he'll
take the resulting pepper then you might
want to wait a turn otherwise i just
ignore and just keep making shockwave
matches to get rid of cages
right so here's a spot where we have a
green pepper that is ready to explode so
even if we had some i don't see any but
if we had some chocolate matches it'd
still be a good idea to explode this
pepper real quick
that's a that's a really good result
there's a couple reasons one is that we
got rid of a bunch of statues and the
other is
later on in the level
a lot of times
these yellow peppers will fill up the
whole bottom and you won't have very
many at the top so this is nice that we
have
at least a blue and a purple down here
now that we might be able to get some
more hits
these crates are still our number one
priority
but since we have blues near two of them
if we can't set up shock waves then
we'll try to uh send we'll try to
explode blue pepper
all right we got part of an l here in
the right spot
we'd have to bring this down somehow
check to see if there's anything else
first but i don't really see anything so
match this purple it'll let us match the
green guess a little bit closer
another thing to pay attention is some
of these rows now aren't really that
important anymore
still like to get rid of this crate but
this one's a lot more important because
we have block statues
all right so now we have a shock wave on
the outside we'll go ahead and take that
we have one large blue pepper here but
no real other ones to go along with it
so
we're better off not growing this at all
right now and leaving these in place for
later
we have part of the gap on the top here
but no way to move it down
i'm going to make this green match
because it's going to slide all this out
of the way
and you know basically i'm just hoping
to get lucky there right i didn't but
you could see how that changed
everything up pretty quick
nothing doing over here
so we have a gap for the blues i'm going
to go ahead and match these greens and
see if the blue drops down and it
doesn't
okay so
now everything's pretty much just a mess
so
that's the fastest way to get some stuff
out of the way
hmm
i was trying to set up a t there right
at work
all right so we have most of the gap
here so we'll try to get a purple on the
drop
it's kind of a tedious process like i
said if you played it before you already
know
all right this this uh l will hit this
statue so we'll go ahead and take that
now we have some more blue big blue
and we have some time before he's going
to get back down there to steal him so
if we can't send the shock wave here
then
growing blue is probably a pretty good
idea one of the problems is that we have
a lot of big green a lot of big purple
so
those might end up
exploding
accidentally while we're in the process
this is kind of interesting this will
hit the statue so it's a good shot but
i'm just wondering if i should maybe
explode this to leave another big one
behind
well these aren't well they will be
though after i explode this
it could go either way there's no other
blue ones
right here right now so i guess we'll
just go for the guaranteed head on the
statue
all right now we have two big blue ones
and and two important spots so we
definitely want to try to get rid try to
get those grown before he takes them out
of the way
i could grow one here
this one i'm gonna lose for sure
yeah i guess that
the reason why i didn't like that one
was because it was going to go off to
the side by itself but it ended up
working out pretty good
all right so now we have
well it all worked out because we had
the shot
usually
um
when you have just one left it's gonna
be like i said these yellow ones seem to
fall into place a lot towards the end
and
they can block things so it's usually
better if you only have one i think to
try to set up the shock wave
we got lucky here and it's just right
there but um
you know i haven't ever seen an example
where we can actually get these yellow
ones to explode at the bottom there's
just not enough of the top so
if you get into that situation then just
try to
set up a shock we have to hit your last
one or
you know in this case you had the purple
i would go for the purple
or the green if you had a whole bunch of
them on there but i'm just going to go
ahead and finish it off
and um that's the way you do it it's
it's a really frustrating level we kind
of like it because
you know there's some thinking involved
in setting up the shots and stuff but it
also can wear you out so
just hang in there
if you're if you're actively setting up
those shots at the top and taking your
time like we did just there
you will be able to set up enough of
them to get through it um
it you know it it's it's not the kind of
level that you're going to be
consistently
it took us a couple tries here and i
think that was our third try until we
got it and um
yesterday when we played it for the
first time it took a bunch of them so
just hang in there and
if you got any questions leave a comment
make sure you like our our facebook page
make sure that you
share this if you found it helpful so
that other people can
um
get past this level as well
we hope it'll help you out and we'll be
making more more new videos soon thanks